[Music]
welcome to another game of thrones
prequel video in which we continue to
talk about its main characters
this time about aegon the second
targaryen if you've watched any of my
previous videos you probably know when
and what about this game of thrones
prequel series is going to be about
but for those that don't let me explain
to you in short notes
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on georgia martin's book
firing blood volume 1.
anton martin's yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
the creator of the armed throne and goes
on to recount the generations of
targaryens who fought to hold that
iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood volume 1. the
yetana released fire and blood volume 2
will continue from there part 1 ended
with rynera targaryen's son egg on the
3rd reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion that ended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war this summer it was
reported then recently confirmed by
entertainment weekly that hb has
released a casting call for prince who
will become king aegon the second
targaryen
a key figure from this time period of
the dance of the dragons
the casting call describes him princess
rhaenyra's younger half-brother who
challenges rhaenyra's claim to the
throne
igniting a civil war miguel sapochnick
and ryan condell will serve as show
runners and executive producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
a war of succession between aegon ii and
his half-sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
round both of them thought they belonged
on the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons for the dragons by the time it
was over thousands were dead
the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well in
addition
it devastated targaryen's dragon
population ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys the first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
one of the main characters in this
series is going to be prince aegon
who will become king aegon the second
targaryen he was named by his mother
after aegon the conqueror
he scolded on the usurper by supporters
of rhaenyra targaryen
and they got the elder to distinguish
from megan the younger rhaenyra's son
aegon ii targaryen was the sixth
targaryen king to sit the armed round
succeeding his father viserys the first
targaryen
as lord of the seven kingdoms his ascent
was disputed by his older half-sister
princess rhaenyra targaryen who had been
their father's designated heir
aegon and rhaenyra fought for the throne
in the civil war the singers called the
dance of the dragons
his dragon was sunfire also known as the
golden
during the dance aegon took a
three-headed golden dragon for his
personal sigil
instead of the red three-headed
targaryen dragon
indicating his mount aegon's supporters
used his personal heraldry as their
battle
flag he bore the iron and ruby crown of
fagon the first targaryen and carried
blackfyre
his namesakes valyrian steel sword aegon
was severely injured
during the dance of the dragons which
left him bent and twisted at rook's nest
aegon broke his ribs
his hip and was burned on half of his
body most severely on his left arm
his burns turned to scars and his
subsequent use of milk of the poppy gave
him a puffy face
later at dragonstone aegon broke both
his legs and was for the remainder of
his life unable to walk
although he was not the first child of
king viserys the first targaryen
aegon was the firstborn son of king
viserys and queen ellis and hightower
when she gave birth to him in 106 ac
aegon ii had younger brothers prince
aemond and prince daron
as well as a sister princess helena as
per traditions of house targaryen aegon
would marry his sister helena in 122 ac
together aegon and helena would have
three children
the twins prince jaehaerys and princess
jahira were born in 123 ac
and prince mailer was born in 127 ac
none of his children lived to adulthood
and his line ended with jahiro's death
in 133ac
although he was viserys's eldest son
viserys had named his zelda's child and
daughter his heir
princess rhaenyra targaryen aegon's
half-sister
rhaenyra and her children by sterling or
valerian and prince daemon targaryen
were to come before aegon's own
conflicting with precedence set by the
great council of 101 ac
rhaenyra had officially been appointed
as viserys is heir in late 105 ac
with hundreds of lords and landing
knights having done obeisance to her
and having stormed solemn oaths to
defend her rights
in his life king viserys named rhaenyra
is there and his will after his death
stayed the same
he wanted his eldest child princess
rhaenyra to succeed him
the ensuring debate and struggle over
the succession gave birth to the dance
of the dragons
then viserys died in 129 ac ultimately
aegon ii
reigned as a king although he would be
succeeded by prince aegan and the
younger
his nephew by rhaenyra and daemon
relations at court began to escalate as
lords began to side with either alicent
or rhaenyra
with many favoring the laws established
at the great council of 101 ac
declaring that the iron throne could not
pass to a woman
the two parties soon became known as the
greens and the blacks
the former consisting of those in favor
of aegon inheriting the iron throne
while the latter favored ryanera when
king viserys the first targaryen died in
129 ac
princess rhaenyra targaryen was still
the heir to the iron throne
since she was pregnant at dragonstone
when her father died
the green sinking's landing hid the news
of viserys's death
keeping the king's body in his room for
seven days until their preparations for
aegon's coronation were complete
with the exception of lord lyman
beesbury the small council agreed to
crown aegon
according to mushroom the prince was
found with a young girl in flee bottom
while septeneustus claimed aegon was
found a bed with a parmer
the daughter of a traitor according to
eusta sagon at first refused to be a
part of his mother's plans to crown him
insisting rhaenyra was there however sir
christian called lord commander of the
kingsguard convince him that should
rhaenyra take the throne
aegon and his brothers would be executed
justice insists that only this persuaded
him to take the crown
on the tenth day of the third moon of
129 ac
the death of king viserys the first was
finally announced to the seven kingdoms
and the aegon was declared a king
preparations were made
to have the coronation at the dragonpit
on the appointed day sir christ and the
kingmaker placed the crown of fagon the
conqueror upon the prince's head
proclaiming him king of the andals the
rhoynar and the first men
however king aegon faced the first
betrayal the same
day when sir stefan darkling of the
kingsguard fled to rhaenyra at
dragonstone
with the crown of viserys the first
rhaenyra refused to be denied her crown
disputing aegon's ascension aegon
enjoyed the wealth of king's landing
oldtown and lennysport
as well as the support of house
hightower lannister and baratheon
he also maintained the appearance of
legitimacy with the conquerors crown the
valyrian steel sword blackfyre and the
armed round
upon hearing of rhaenyra's coronation
aegon demanded the heads of her and
prince daemon
although grandma's roar will convince
taegon to allow him to give peace terms
to rhaenyra
however rhaenyra refused the terms much
to the anger of aegon
the realm was split in two as the greens
and the blacks battled for the iron
throne
and the civil war known as the dance of
the dragons began
early in the war prince seaman slew
prince lost service valerian over
storm's end
by luceris was attempting to win boris
baratheon
lord of storm's end over to his mother's
side
upon aemon's return having ensured
storms and support
aegon welcomed his brother with a great
feast although queen elisen and her
father sir odo hightower the hand of the
king
were concerned about the extent of
aemon's actions
seeking revenge against aegon prince
daemon took action
aegon's heir prince geherys was killed
in the red keep
by blood and cheese agents of miseria
daemon spymaster
while blood was captured and tortured to
death cheese who was a rat catcher was
not found
in his fury aegon ordered every red
catcher in the city to be hanged
while the green suffered a series of
defeats in the riverlands where otto
attempted to win allies with letters and
buying sellswords
aegon mistook his efforts for inaction
and his caution for cover this
with house valerian house stark house
serene and many of the river
firmly behind his sister aegon drowned
his growing fears in strong wine
with corliss valerian lord of the tides
blockading king's landing
otto reached out to the triarchy and
delton greyjoy
lord of the iron islands for aid because
of his grandfather's delays in waging
war
aegon stripped toto of the handship and
awarded it to kristen cole
sir kristen soon took to the offensive
aegon himself took the field in a trap
set by the kingmaker
at rook's rest where he and eamonn
fought and killed princess rainey's
targaryen
the queen who never was and her dragon
melees
however some fire were badly maimed by
rhaenys and millies
and aegon suffered from burns that
covered half his body
a broken hip and numerous broken ribs
his armor had melted into his left arm
and it would take him a year to recover
eamonn took over the rule in his status
prince regent
and protector of the realm aegon
remained bent and twisted for the rest
of his life
have his body covered in burnt scars
rhaenyra took king's landing and the
iron throne in 130 ac
aemond and daemon slew each other in the
battle above the god's eye
and kristen perished in the butcher's
ball before they could be captured by
rhaenyra however
larry strong lord of heronhall secretly
smuggled aegon and his children out of
the city
while his children were spirited away to
safety
aegon disguised himself as one of the
small folk and escaped on a fishing boat
later arriving on dragonstone where he
convinced several blacks to defect and
help him take the island
during the fall of dragonstone he fought
daemon's daughter
princess baila targaryen both of them
mounted on dragons
when some fire and moon dancer fell to
the earth during the fight
aegon tried to jump off his dragon's
back shattering his legs
meanwhile again's wife helena had ended
her grief by jumping out of her room in
the capital
and his son prince mailer was killed by
a mob in bitter bridge
following the storming of the dragon pit
rhaenyra fled to dragonstone in 1 30 ac
unaware of aegon's coup she was captured
on arrival
judge the traitor and fed by aegon to
sunfire
as rhaenyra's surviving sun prince sage
and the younger watched
sir alfred broome argued for killing
prince aegon as well
although the king forbade it however the
war continued
as rhaenyra supporters continued her
cause supporting aegon the younger
despite the boy being aegon the elders
prisoner
although rhaenyra was dead the dance of
the dragons was not yet over
as those loyal to her continued the
fight in the name of her son aegon the
younger
the river lords marched towards king's
landing while large hosts from the vale
of ferran was hiring ships to bring them
down on the capital
aegon made efforts to hatch dragon x
from dragonstone
but to no success although aegon ii
desired for his sister's line to end
aegon decreed that the prince would
either join the night's watch
or serve him as a eunuch with armies
closing in on the capital and his lords
plotting and arguing
aegon ii remained oblivious however
kermit tully lord of riveran
and his army had defeated lord boris
baratheon in the battle of the king's
road
with no green armies remaining the lads
marching on the capital
and with the additional approach of the
veilman and the northern army of cragan
stark
lord of vanerfel lord corliss valerian
no defeat was imminent in 131ac
he counseled king aegon to abdicate and
join the night's watch
but the king refused he instead gave
orders to have the year of his nephew
prince sake and the younger cut off and
sent to lord tully as a warning
after his meeting with the small council
the fatigue dagon climbed into his
litter
and asked to be carried to the royal
sept the king had his customary flagon
of sweet arbor red along the way to ease
his pain
when his escort arrived and the knight
of the kingsguard lifted the litter's
curtains
eggon ii was found dead with blood on
his lips vitagon the second dead
lord coralie sent an unharmed egg and
the younger rolled out to meet the
vanguard of kermitaly's host
proclaiming the king was dead the late
king had no male heirs left
which led to his nephew aegon the
younger rhaenyra's son ascending to the
iron throne
who exactly poisoned the king remains
unknown although those judged
responsible were arrested for the crime
during the hour of the wolf
when lord craig and stark took over the
capital even though lord stark was on
rhinera's side
he still wanted those who broke their
loyalty towards aegon the second
punished
because they could do the same in the
future to rhaenyra's son aegon iii
the main suspects in aegon ii's death
were lord valerian
lord larry strong and sir perk in the
flea who feared the take on the second
remaining of the armed round would lead
to continued war
lord stark had 26 traitors arrested
judged and punished or spared
it's often agreed by many that no one
really won the dance of the dragons
but it's a fact that rhaenyra's
loyalists won the war
and rainer's children got the throne
despite being considered as part of the
targaryen dynasty history would not be
kind to aegon ii
even though it's equally unkind to his
half-sister rhaenyra
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace
you